this is it this is it very minimalist
eyesore but I've seen other shows you're
on a cat you you changed it from a couch
the budget budget went down yeah right
you had a couch though right there were
there were couches there have been puffy
chairs yes I when I get I get the
electric electrocution chair yeah that's
okay we could hook it up to a car
battery by the way I know you've
mentioned Everybody Loves Raymond right
on that side of that wall that's where
we filmed stage 5 no way I'm a hundred
yards away getting paid a million
dollars less I have my New York Italian
relatives with me today Danny yes
they're on my wife's side right they're
right here
that is incredible ok fix Italian
Italian New Yorkers are visiting staying
in my house
I took them here because cuz you're it's
closer than Disneyland yeah I'm kind of
like goofy one of them doesn't really
speak English Murray no not Nona Nana
doesn't speak English buongiorno well
speak Italia I'm sorry ma no speaking
Beijing so watch it
she'll one move in you're dead she can
have you she can have you taken out do
you speaking Italian I do not speak
Italian no they all do my wife does but
I don't you should have picked you pick
I figured I should were married 26 years
I should pick up something Wow that's
how by the way that's a comment on
marriage III endorsed marriage but if
this is how hard it is that you get
applause if you do it for a long time
if I said you know because it's hard if
I said I've eaten ice cream for 26 years
straight they're not clapping okay
it's you've been mad well that's hard
yeah because if you're eating vanilla
ice cream you're allowed to also eat
strawberry chocolate yes in the same
bowl you cook in the same bowl
I called Neapolitan and ice cream
three-way you know it's very funny you
mentioned that because speaking of that
three-way is not yes/no for guys who are
about to get better or married my wife
posed this question this is not a legal
question that a woman should ask she
said this true sorry she said I would
never do it but if I ever agreed to a
threesome which one of my friends would
you choose yes yeah you can't you can't
and of course you can't answer
there's no right thing you actually have
to like start a fire in your house to
get out of that but here's what you if
you do answer I was stupid enough to
answer yes make sure you understand the
question don't name two of her friends
you include her she's in there I didn't
do the math yeah I didn't do the math
right not a fart way a three-way without
her I you know you here I took things
literally I didn't yeah I don't know